I want to pull up this tweet from the
DeSantis war room and uh okay my let's
pull this out my personal opinion is
slightly negative on this Suite I think
it is cringe I think DeSantis team is
correct and they deserve so on on the
political point of this video they
deserve the credit their criticisms are
fair but man you guys ready for this oh
yeah they tweeted to wrap up pride month
let's hear from the politician who did
more than any other Republican to
celebrate it here we go
how can you fix the audio yeah try it
now
nope wait I will do everything in my
power to protect
our LG ttq citizens but Caitlyn Jenner
would walk into Trump Tower and want to
use the bathroom you would be fine with
her using any bathroom she choose is
that is correct in the future can
transgender women compete in this
universe yes make America great again
just produced some of the harshest most
Draconian laws that literally threaten
trans existence congratulations Robert
Sanders mission accomplished you win
I can't do it
okay I I like the music I think the
point being made is correct I don't I am
not as critical As Trump for you know in
the past when he held up the LGBT flag
and all that stuff he is not talking
about what we are currently saying he
was talking about other things there are
many people that we are friends of and
fans of that previously did align
themselves with the traditional LGBT
stuff and Trump I believe was correct to
be like hey those people are good
they're going to vote for us what we're
seeing now is very very different does a
mirror move that I think is wrong but
Trump absolutely was not as as harsh
Rana Santos is absolutely going after
this in the culture War more so than any
other leader
but the American Psycho bit and the Chad
meme stuff it's just it's it's too like
if they took that out and just showed
clips of DeSantis like pointing to the
press and like answering questions with
news articles I'd give it an A plus the
weird meme things is too much like I'm
with a turtle kids I like it I have a
preference for Trump over to Santos but
I I like this video I think it's good do
you like it sketching yeah I like it
over the top yeah the music works for
sure yeah yeah they only need to show
Brad Pitt's face once they showed it
twice and American Psycho that was great
yeah the second shot of the cycle oh
good I just it's like is is he trying to
align himself with being a psychopath no
it's very gen Z so the Patrick Bateman
the the American Psycho memes those are
big on Tick Tock and when should I say
so it's very I I guess you're the one
that stuck with it but but that's my
point like Rhonda Sanders is older than
me why is he like trying to like are the
kids gonna be like wow he's so cool
We're Not Gonna vote for him anyways uh
statistically gen Z just doesn't turn
out but are you gen Z yeah you're gonna
vote for him right no would you would
you vote for him if it wasn't Trump
no really no who's on your who's your
top contenders right now I don't know
I don't know to be honest Trump would be
at the I have a preference for Trump at
the moment what about Vivek I do like
Vivek a lot and um Robert F Kennedy Jr
RFK I love because he challenges the
system but he's still anti-2a yeah oh so
but I do I I will support him just
because I think he has an important
message he still is a Democrat so if you
leave Republican you're not gonna like
him yeah I was this this Trump stuff I
didn't know that Trump was all in on the
inviting see this is the thing if
someone had asked him are you okay with
letting a trans-political movement
indoctrinate children into becoming
trans and having sex surgeries he
probably would have been like no like
what are you talking about of course
that's crazy so I don't think this is
stuff from back in 2015 yeah eight years
he didn't see it coming I mean remember
it whenever he debated Palin Joe Biden
was against gay marriage everyone's
opinion shifts over time especially if
their their uh political cohorts change
their opinion and I think we have to
give trouble a lot of credit when he was
talking in 2015 no one knew exactly
where it's going some people could have
predicted that we'd be selling uh gender
affirming bathing suits to children and
Target but not a lot of people
those are for adults it's just gender
affirming when it's for children so what
Ian said it's like listen I love the
pride flag because now I know if I'm on
like a street I know which are the gay
bars oh that's a gay bar so I think you
know that's good that we should have
pride Flags I'm not like against you
know canceling the pride flag but what
does a pride Flag symbolize is it the
only difference between me and a gay
person or a straight person a gay person
is their sexual preference so this flag
basically indicates your sexual
preference why does that need to be in a
school like that does that need to be on
a flag well I mean I listen you want to
have that on a flag go ahead you want to
do butt stuff and have a flag for it
actually go ahead but why are we going
to put it in the kindergarten classroom
that's where and I think even though
they're kind of trolling Trump I think
Trump like you said would probably have
that same feeling like obviously gay
people exist but I just don't want you
grooming my children yeah right I also
think just both the Trump and DeSantis
teams on social media especially on
Twitter are really cringe it's just
getting too much yeah
dude I just just just stop I look if
this really worked for Gen Z I stand
corrected if if the kids on Tick Tock
are watching this video and now they're
inspired to vote for DeSantis they're
not going all right
I think it's good I don't think it was
made by them either they're reposting
proud elephant I'm just like
it's it's getting I don't know man it's
cringe it's it's cringe on both sides
yeah but I think it's something to
Santa's influencer what's what's gonna
happen though is the Trump influencers
and the DeSantis influencers are just
going to kill themselves and we're gonna
have the same outcome of 2020 probably
they're gonna they're gonna nuke each
other in the primary then refuse to vote
for each other that's what we need is
the Trump DeSantis get along meme of
course grab arms and they're like
together they should just fight in the
Coliseum oh that would be winner gets
the nomination I I I uh won't vote for
DeSantis on if if he apologizes has his
team apologize and take down that deep
fake video then he's back on my list
but it's like at this point we're over a
month out I don't know if it's there's
he probably didn't even approve that it
doesn't matter yeah I guess how hard
would it be for him to be like take it
down yeah I didn't approve of that take
it down that was wrong sorry about that
guys that's all five seconds if he put
out a video and you and if they just
delete here's the thing if they delete
the tweet and then put up a tweet saying
we deleted that video because it had
deep fakes Ron is unhappy that it that
it was put up without his approval it is
no longer you know then I would be like
okay cool is your issue with the
dishonesty of the defense like so for
almost a decade the media has been lying
about every single thing Trump has ever
done and it's more than lying it's one
it's one thing when you have these
political videos that are like did you
know that you know John Smith voted for
the for the uh hating puppies act or
like you know Alex Stein voted against
the we love puppies Bill why doesn't he
love puppies it's like oh that Bill had
nothing to do with puppies like we get
it it's manipulation
that's annoying it's bad and everybody
hates it
with trump it was even worse they were
editing videos out of context lying
about his quotes and I spend almost the
better like the better part of a decade
constantly talking to everybody saying
that's not true that never happened and
it is annoying and I hate having to do
it all the time and then Rhonda Sanders
comes out with a video his team did
where they they made deep fake images of
trump hugging and kissing fauci and so
now it's just like all of that stuff I'm
angry about they just decided to one-up
it so I'm pissed yeah last bad president
too right like we're gonna have a
republican candidate attack another
Republican candidate by fabricating
something like yeah that would never
work for journalism why are we allowing
it to stand for social media because
otherwise we just open the door for it I
would be a hypocrite if I said ah it's
no big deal because I've been
complaining about the media lying about
Trump non-stop the entire time now don't
get me wrong people are like yeah but
Trump lies about DeSantis and I'm like
and he should not but he did not create
fake images to smear Rhonda he kind of
did and again I have a question I have a
preference for Trump again what did
Trump what did Trump create he didn't no
he didn't do an AI but they were posting
photos of the empty DeSantis Booth
saying nobody came by all day but that
wasn't the case and they ended up
getting Community noted on it it's it's
all dishonest and I think on both and
it's bad and I hate all of it yeah and
the Trump Camp shouldn't be posting
misleading things but it is
substantially worse to have someone go
onto a computer and create several
different iterations of fake images to
trick people into thinking a thing
happened that didn't happen well it's
fair and I'm not trying to be a
contrarian or White Knight for DeSantis
I love
Donald Trump
but Donald Trump was
besties with fauci in a way I mean I
know those are artists I agree with the
point I know I mean they were kind of
made even though they used a fake
artificial photo they were making a true
point so it's kind of I know hey I'm
just saying that to be contrarian if
they didn't do that the video is fine
yeah but instead
they do it I say hey that's not cool you
should take that down and then they
attack me for it and I'm just like okay
these people are disingenuous like how
about you prove that you're better than
all of the BS we've been dealing with is
Trump posting out of context Clips or
whatever like every other position
always does and we all despise it okay
that's really bad and I'm annoyed by it
he's as bad as all the rest of them did
DeSantis just do worse than all of them
great all the politicians are at
Baseline lying pieces of trash and
DeSantis is one degree below them that's
where I'm at so you know all you gotta
do is tweet and be like we shouldn't
have done that and I'll say okay okay
guys because I gotta look this video
they're right Rhonda Santos has it has
really done a lot as it pertains to the
culture war and in protecting kids and
and putting up barriers to protect the
cultural values and the moral values
that we do have and that's a winning
position that's fantastic it's better
than Trump he's got a lot to go after
Trump on in terms of the primary
but they're certainly not doing
themselves any favor with this current
press team they seem to be just digging
a hole for him no and he's a young man I
don't know why he's making this push now
I think he I guess maybe sees blood in
the water maybe like a shark right now I
think he sees Trump as vulnerable you
see Candace Owens tweeted that as he's
done who DeSantis said that he's done
let me let me let me pull that tweet up
yeah but I don't think they're gonna
stop trying to investigate Trump I mean
I don't think that's not I mean it's
never going to stop they're gonna find
something I mean it's just it's gonna a
never-ending Cavalcade of charges to try
to stop him from running and I think
it's going to win I think that there
will be a time and I know Trump says
he'll fight till the end or whatever but
I think there'll be a time where they'll
say hey I mean this is just pure
speculation where maybe he does get in
trouble for a crime and I think they're
kind of laying the groundwork for Biden
to get in trouble for a similar crime
and then maybe they both get pardoned
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
on uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time